OF THE- NINE ELEVEN MEETING OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING THE
BILL'S INSIDE IN ORDER IS
MISTER BONTA WERE YOU TO SEE
THE FIRST TO SIGN IN. HEY
MISTER BONTA. WE'RE GONNA BE
LIMITING THE TESTIMONY FROM THE
WITNESSES TO TWO MINUTES APIECE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
AFTER TAKING A MOMENT IN THE
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER. COMMITTEE AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW THE CITY OF OAKLAND THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION THE SAM
JUST KOBE CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION OR BE
CDC IN THE PORT OF OAKLAND AS
WELL AS THE OPEN DAYS HAVE ALL.
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER OVER THE
PAST SIX MONTHS IN A PLAN FOR
PRIVATELY FINANCED BALLPARK
THAT ONE FOR THE AGES STAY IN
OAKLAND. A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE WILL SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE HOWARD
TERMINAL SITE IN OAKLAND A
DEVELOPMENT THAT WILL INCLUDE A
BALL PARK FOR THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS AS WELL AS MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING INCLUDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PUBLIC GREEN
SPACE RETAIL AND WATER FRONT
ACCESS. AS MANY OF YOU ON THIS
COMMITTEE KNOW THIS PROJECT
ALREADY HAD TO MEET SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS SUCH AS
LEGAL CERTIFICATION THAT ZERO
GHG EMISSIONS ETCETERA. IN
ADDITION TO THE STRICT
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS IT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT TO
WORK WITH THE FIVE AFTER
MENTIONED OR ORGANIZATIONS TO
MAKE THIS BILL STRONG AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'VE DONE SINCE WE WERE
IN YOUR COMMITTEE LAST.
SPECIFICALLY THE NEW AMENDMENTS
TAKEN AND SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER INCLUDE
NUMBER ONE REQUIRING THE OPEN
DAYS TO OBTAIN ALL NECESSARY
LOCAL APPROVALS. FROM THE CITY
IN THE PORT WITH AT LEAST ONE
PUBLIC HEARING PRIOR TO A
PUBLIC TRUST IT I'M A NATION BY
STATE LANCE NUMBER TWO ENSURING
THE OPENED A IS FILE A MAJOR
PERMIT APPLICATION. FOR THE
OAKLAND SPORTS A MIXED USE
PROJECT AT HOWARD TERMINAL WITH
THE CDC AND FINALLY NUMBER
THREE REQUIRING REPORTING
LANGUAGE ON THE TRUST PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTED BY THE PROPONENTS
TO FULFILL ITS PUBLIC TRUST
RESPONSIBILITIES. PREVIOUSLY IN
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES I
SHOULD THE COMMITTEE THAT A. B.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS NOT DID
NOT REMOVE STATE LAND
COMMISSION AUTHORITY AND NOW
WITH THIS VERSION OF THE BILL.
THAT GUARANTEES REAFFIRMED
LIKEWISE A. B. NINETY ONE
REQUIRES A MAJOR PERMIT THAT
MUST BE APPROVED BY THE CDC
BEFORE ANY CONTRACTS OR
CONSTRUCTION CAN BE IN EMPOWER
TERMINAL. I BELIEVE. I HAVE
WORKED. IN GOOD FAITH WITH THE
FIVE AFTER MENTIONED
STAKEHOLDERS ON HIS OWN AND
WITH BOTH. NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEES IN THE ASSEMBLY IN
THE SENATE. HOPE THAT THAT YOU
IN MEMBERS WILL AGREE I BELIEVE
THAT AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS
VITAL TO KEEPING THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS ROOTED IN OAKLAND.
AND I BELIEVE IT IS SOUND
POLICY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRPERSON MY NAME IS THE
LONGER ELLIS. AND I'M THE
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS I JUST WANNA COME
BRIEFLY AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL
AS ASSEMBLYMAN BONTA MENTIONED
WE WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THAT WILL
ENABLE A PRIVATELY FINANCED
BALLPARK IN THE CITY OF OAKLAND
WE WORK WITH THE CDC STATE
LANDS THE PORT AND THE CITY AND
ALSO OUR FRIENDS IN LABOR AND
THE TRADES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAME UP WITH THE BILL TO DO
SOMETHING VERY SIGNIFICANT IN
THE CITY. WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON
FRIEDMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY NATIONAL NATURAL.
RESOURCES COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THIS
MORNING MY NAME'S MOLLY MAE
BROWN I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF OAKLAND MAYOR SENSOR
APOLOGIES THAT SHE COULD NOT BE
HERE. ON SHORT NOTICE BUT I AM
HERE TO EXPRESS THE STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CITY OF OAKLAND
FOR THIS BILL AND ALSO OUR
APPRECIATION TO. COMMITTEE
STAFF THE CDC STAFF STATE LAND
STAFF THE AUTHORS OFFICE PORT
IN A IS THIS. THE HUSBAND. LAB
PROF AS- I'M AND I THINK THAT.
THE INVOLVEMENT AND THE
COLLABORATIVE WORK OF ALL OF
THESE FOLKS HAS MADE THIS BILL
STRONGER. AND THE PROJECT
BETTER AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO AS WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY
THROUGH THE BUILD OUT OF THE
NEW BALLPARK. AND A COMMUNITY
ON THE WATERFRONT POWER
TERMINAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. I'M SURE
MEMBERS AS FOR THE OTHER BEHALF
FOR THE STATE TO THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. OF
FOR THE REASONS ALREADY STATED
ALSO WON A PRE SAID IN OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR THE
OAKLAND ETS. THE PORT THE CITY
AND EVERYONE THAT WORKED ON
THIS OP ON THIS BUT A BILL IT'S
BEEN A LONG PROCESS BUT IT'S
BEEN A CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED
PROCESS THE BALANCES OUT. THE
NEEDS OF THE REGION'S
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
NECESSITY SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ASK YOUR I WROTE. THANK YOU
OTHER OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY
JUST NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
GOOD MORNING SCOTT SAILOR
BEHALF OF THE- PORT OF OAKLAND
IN SUPPORT. MY NAME'S QADER AS
IN I LIVE AND WORK IN OAKLAND
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS SERRA HOOVER I
ALSO LIVE AND WORK IN OAKLAND
AND STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. MY NAME'S MILITIA MY
GREW UP IN LIVE IN AND WORK IN
OAKLAND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MY NAME'S ERICA GEORGE I
LIVE AND WORK IN OAKLAND AND I
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT. COLLETTE
LOOK IS CON ALL WORKING LIVE IN
OAKLAND AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. CURTIS WHO AGAIN TEN
NOT WORKING OUT THEN I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. KRISTIN
CHENEY WORK IN OAKLAND AND VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING JASON BRIGHT ON
BEHALF THE DOWNTOWN OAKLAND
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT
WOULD SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. OKAY IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AT MEMBERS I AM
ERROR RIGHT I L. W. LOCAL TEN
BUSINESS AGENT REPRESENTING. A
COUPLE THOUSAND WORKERS IN THE
PORT. ALSO A MEMBER OF. THE
EAST OAKLAND STADIUM ALLIANCE
WHICH IS A CONGLOMERATE OF EAST
OAKLAND OF CHURCHES IN
RESIDENTS BUSINESSES. RANGING
FROM AGRIBUSINESS OF RAIL.
TRUCKING IN OF SHIPPING
COMPANIES AND WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS BILL.
PASSING AN UPSTATE IN BEING
BUILT IN A CRITICAL CHOKE POINT.
AT HOWARD TERMINAL WHERE OUR
TRUCKING LINES GO THROUGH OUR
SHIP TURNING CIRCLE IS OUR RAIL
LINES GO THROUGH THERE YOU KNOW
THE ITS CLAIM THAT THIS IS
SUPPOSED TO BE A PRIVATELY
FINANCED PARK WILL BY WITH YOU
NEED. A BILL TO CREATE TAX
DISTRICTS. THAT'S ASIDE FROM
THIS ONE BUT- IT'S CLEARLY NOT
GONNA BE PRIVATE. THIS IS THE.
THIS THESE LAWS WERE CREATED TO
PROTECT PORT LANDS THEY WERE
CREATED TO KEEP RESIDENTS OUT
OF THE PORT OF TIDE WATER WHERE
DEEP WATER PORT YOU CANNOT
CREATED NEW PORT. YOU CANNOT
MAKE. NEW WATERFRONT SPACE. THE
PORT OF OAKLAND IS THE THIRD
LARGEST ON THE WEST COAST AND
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE THIS
RESOURCE. IT AFFECTS THOUSANDS
OF REAL JOBS IN INDUSTRY. THE.
BUILDING TRADES ARE SUPPORTING
THIS THEY CAN WORK AND BUILD IN
EAST OAKLAND A SITE SEEK WOULD
ALREADY THREE TIMES AS LARGE AS
HOWARD TERMINAL YOU CAN BUILD
THREE TIMES THE STADIUM HOUSES
AND HOTELS THERE. AND KEEP THE
PORT OF OAKLAND VIABLE. AND THE
ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA STRONG
FOR THE WORKING PEOPLE HERE IN
THE BUSINESSES THAT RELY ON THE
PORT THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JOSH WAS SHOT WITH THE
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION V. ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE MARITIME
SHIPPERS A MOVER CARGO IN AND
OUT OF THESE PORTS AS WELL AS
THE COMPANIES. THAT LEASE THE
PROPERTY FROM THE PORTS WE ARE
PART OF THE EAST OAKLAND
STATING ALLIANCE OPPOSED TO THE
PROJECT THE BILL IS UNNECESSARY
WITH ALL THE PROTECTIONS THAT
THE AUTHOR MENTIONED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IN YOUR STAFF YOUR
COUNTERPART IN THE SENATE AND
HIS AND THAT YOUR STAFF. AND
THE AUTHOR PRESUMABLY FOR
WEARING SOME OF THE WORST
APPETITES OF THE AIDS WITH ALL
THOSE PROTECTIONS WHY DO YOU
NEED A BATTLE STATE LAW ALLOWS
THE STATE LAW AUTHORIZES THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION A. B. C.
DC. TO MAKE ALL THE RIGHT
DECISIONS THERE IS NO TITLE
DISPUTE IN FACT THE MOST RECENT
MEMBERS TO THE BILL LIST QUITE
CLEARLY WHO OWNS THE TITLE
WHERE THIS PROJECT IS WHERE THE
DIFFERENT LAYERS ARE. AGAIN IF
THERE WAS A TITLE DISPUTE TO
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
<c.green>OULD WITH ITS EXISTING</c>
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY FIGURE
THAT ALL OUT IT'S REALLY A LAND
DEVELOPMENT DEAL I WONDER IF
ALL THE GREAT YOUNG PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE THERE EVER BE ABLE
FOR THE MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
UNDER THOSE AT THE AGE PLAN TO
TELL AT THIS SITE. AT THE SO
THE MAIN TIME ACTIVITY. IS KING
POSTED. YEAH ONE OF US FROM
GOING TO ESTABLISH REFORM WE
CAN ROLL CALL PLEASE. NUMBER
THREE TEN. MORE. LARA HERE CHAU
CHAU HERE EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE
GARCIA THE MALL MATHIS THERE
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY MELENDEZ
WROTE SURGERY STONE STONE HERE
THANK YOU HAVE A QUORUM. I
THINK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR STILL WERE
IN OPPOSITION AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE A BECAUSE IT DOES INTRODUCE
SOME NEW CHALLENGES TO OUR
BUSINESSES WHICH IS WHICH IS
LOCATED DIRECTLY ADJACENT TO
OUR TERMINAL WERE A RECYCLING
FACILITY PROCESSING STEEL IT'S
A- FORM OF HEAVY INDUSTRY THAT
WON'T OF PLAY WELL WITH THE
TYPE OF CONDO LUXURY
DEVELOPMENTS ARE BEING PURPOSE
FOR THIS SITE WE ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE A
TRICK THAT THE INTRODUCTION OF
NEW. TRANSPORTATION CONFLICTS
JUST BY NATURE OF HAVING OF
FOLKS IN THAT THAT LOCATION
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THROUGHOUT
THE DAY SO AND FORTUNE WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE. US FOR NEW
BOOK. THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. YOU CAN COME UP
TO THE MIKE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LARA KNOWING HE CHECK ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN AG PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS STATED. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE OKAY. WITH THAT I
WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THEIR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR. MR BONTA WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES I WANTED
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR
THAT THE DEBATE AND DISCUSSION
TODAY. THERE WILL BE. A LONG
PROCESS STILL AHEAD EVEN IF
THIS BILL PASSES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE CITY IN THE PORT. THE
CDC STATE LANDS AT ALL TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE INPUT AND- TO
PUT THE FINGERPRINTS ON ON WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT AYE AYE AYE
REPRESENT THE PORT OF OAKLAND.
THE COMMISSION REPRESENTS THE
PORT OF OAKLAND OUT WE ARE
SUPPORTING THIS PROJECT BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROJECT IS
GOOD FOR THE REGION GOOD FOR
OAKLAND AND THAT IS ALSO
SOMETHING THAT CAN CO EXIST
WITH A SUCCESSFUL PORT. I THINK
IT THESE I AM CONCLUSORY
STATEMENTS THAT ARE SUGGESTING
IN INTERFERENCE OR OR DETRIMENT
TO THE PORT I THINK I DON'T SEE
THE POSSIBILITY OF A GOOD
PLANNING AND YOU KNOW THE
THINGS THAT GRADE SEPARATION
BUFFER ZONES THAT CAN ADDRESS
ISSUES AND MAKE. MAKE THIS
PROJECT WORK SO I THIS IS
EXCITING PROJECT WITH A LOT OF
STATE POLITICAL WORKING ON THIS
FOR A LONG TIME THIS IS A BILL
THE TYPE OF WHICH HAS BEEN USE
MULTIPLE TIME TO THE STATE TO
MAKE SURE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
INPUT. AND HELPED CRAFT THE
BEST SOLUTION AS WELL AS THE
KEY STAKEHOLDERS IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO TO CRAFT THE BEST
POLICY WE'VE DONE THAT.
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR AND I AM.
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN WITHOUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE ON TO THE FLOOR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU I BELIEVE
THE BILL DOES PRESERVE THE
AUTHORITY INDISCRETIONS OF BC
DC IN THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION SO I CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL TODAY.
ON THE FLOORS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED AND WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
BROKE. HI TO DELIVER ON BY
BONTA. MOTION IS OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA. FLORA AYE CHAU. CHAU AYE
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
LIMóN LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY MELENDEZ READ
THROUGH G. STONE STONE I. YOU
THE SENTIMENTS OF INTEGRATED.
THANK YOU MANAGER THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
THANK YOU OUR NEXT ITEM IS SB
FIFTY FOUR BY ALAN. I DO NOT
SEE THE SENATOR AB SOMEBODY AND.
THE SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE
SENATOR'S OFFICE
. IT IS
COMMITTEE JUST
. YEAH YEAH YEAH.
YEAH OKAY. YEAH. THE
. YEAH.
MARTIN. THE CAMERA. AND A LOT
OF
. YEAH. THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE. YEAH. YEAH
. THE PROCESS
WILL BE
. OKAY. PERFECT ANYTHING
COMING. OUT OF. OR CALL
. YEAH.
TRANSACTION
. AND SO OKAY. SO
ARE LAST TIME AROUND WE HAD A
ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT BOTH SB
FIFTY FOUR. I WHEN WE WHEN THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD THE BILL. IN
JUNE ARE WE VERY CLEARLY HEARD
CONCERNS FROM MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HI THAT WE NEED TO DO
MORE WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO ADDRESS REAL CONCERNS. WE
REALLY DID TAKE THOSE CONCERNS
TO HEART. AND I GOT TO SAY WE
WORK TIRELESSLY OVER THE SUMMER
AND I JUST HAVE TO. GIVE A BIG
SHOUT OUT TO THE STAFF
ESPECIALLY WHO JUST WORK SO
HARD TO. SOLVE FOR EVERY ISSUE
THAT WAS SOLVABLE AND I DON'T
SAY THAT. LATELY WE HAD
COUNTLESS CONVERSATIONS ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THE MINISTRATION.
IT'S ADDRESS TO THE BILL NOW IN
PRINT REFLECTS NUMEROUS CHANGES
THAT WE MADE BASED ON THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THE RECYCLING
RATES IN THE BILL ARE NOW
MATERIAL NEUTRAL SO AS TO NOT
PICK WINNERS AND LOSERS AMONG
MATERIAL TYPES AND THEY DON'T
AS A RESULT THEY DON'T THEY DO
NOT RESULT IN THE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN OR PENALTY. UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN INCLUDES
EVALUATING POTENTIAL END USE
MARKETS FOR MATERIAL. AND
EVALUATING TRANSITIONING OTHER
RECYCLING PROGRAMS. ARE THE
ROLE RETAILERS HAS BEEN
CLARIFIED UNDER THE BILL GIVING
THEM SOME CERTAINTY AS TO HOW
THE PROGRAM WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
THAT WAS VERY MEANINGFUL TO
PEOPLE. THEBASELINE
CALCULATION OFFER WASTE
REDUCTION HAS BEEN STREAMLINED
AND NOW REALIZE AN EXISTING
SERVICE BY POWER CYCLE. OUR
BUSINESSES CAN COMPLY. WITH THE
SOURCE REDUCTION ELEMENT IN THE
BILL BY COMPLETING CHECKLIST
THAT INCLUDES CONSIDERATION
SUCH AS PROJECT PRODUCT
PROTECTION. AND SHELF LIFE IS
EXCESS AS SUGGESTED BY OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. HOW WE CLARIFY
THE NO REGULATIONS DEVELOP INTO
THIS BILL COULD CONFLICT WITH
ANY FEDERAL REGULATIONS OR
LAWS. AND I WILL I WILL SAY
THIS IS AN IT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP
WE'VE SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT
LAWS RELATING TO FOOD AND DRUG
SAFETY. I AS REQUESTED BY
CONSUMER HEALTH CARE PRODUCTS
AND AGRICULTURE. HI ANDWE'VE
SO WE MADE IT REALLY CLEAR THAT
IF THERE'S ANY HEALTH OR SAFETY
IMPLICATIONS. THOSE THOSE
ISSUES ARE ON ARE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED AND- AND IF THERE'S
ANY VIOLATION OF HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS THE THOSE
PRODUCTS WILL BE. ARE EXEMPT.
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR EXEMPTIONS
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. OUR WE'VE
ADDED AN INDEPENDENT
STAKEHOLDER PANEL TO CONSULT
AND PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
CARRY CYCLE TO ENSURE GREATER
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT IN ALL
ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM. I WE
HAD A MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
PRODUCERS CHOOSING TO FORMA
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION AND
MAKE CLEAR THAT NO ENERGY CAN
BE REQUIRED TO JOIN A STORAGE
OF ORGANIZATION THAT'S ANOTHER.
IMPORTANT THING TO MENTION
THERE'S. THERE'S NO COERCION
HERE HIDE IT BUT IT IS AN
OPTION. WE'VE ADDED THE ABILITY
FOR CAROL TO CHARGE A
REGULATORY FEE FOR THE COST OF
THEIR WORKLOAD IMPLANTING THE
PROGRAM. WHICH IS HOW SIMILAR
PROGRAMS IN THE DEPARTMENT AND
AS WELL AS OTHER DEPARTMENTS
WITH ANY PAIR FUNDED THIS IS
THE PROP TWENTY SIX IS GOVERNED
BY BY THOSE RULES. MOST
RECENTLY WE ALSO AMENDED THE
BILL TO DELAY PHASING IN C. R.
V. CONTAINERS INTO THE PROGRAM
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY SIX THIS
ENSURES THAT THEY GET CREDIT
FOR THE INVESTMENT. AND WORK
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE AS PART OF
THE BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM BUT
STILL ENSURES THAT THE
EVENTUALLY ARE SUBJECT TO THE
REQUIRED RECYCLING RATES AND
REGULATIONS. SO. WE ARE WE
HEARD FOLKS HERE SAY WE HADN'T
DONE ENOUGH HOMEWORK WE'RE HERE
IN JUNE LET ME JUST TELL YOU
THE RESULTS OF OUR HOMEWORK
BECAUSE THESE CHANGES AND I
THINK ANYBODY'S BEEN INVOLVED
WITH BILLS UNDERSTAND HOW HARD
IT IS TO CRAFT THESE THINGS TO
ADDRESS THE KINDS OF CONCERNS
THAT WE'VE ADDRESSED WHILE ALSO
MAINTAINING THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR GOALS SO ARE WE NOT
COVERING GROSSES AS HE
SHOULDN'T IN SUPPORT. DOW
CHEMICAL COMPANY IS IN SUPPORT
MANY OTHER GROUPS HAVE GONE
NEUTRAL LET'S GO THROUGH THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL.
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
DURING GAMBLE S. C. JOHNSON THE
CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
TECH NET WALMART CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
CRAFT BREWERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA BEER AND BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTORS ANHEUSER BUSCH
MILLER COURSE PEPSI ARE BOTH
THE BILLS SB FIFTY FOUR AND
TWENTY WERE REMOVED FROM THE
CHAMBERS JOCULAR LIST I THIS IS
ALL TO SAY THAT WE REALLY DID
TAKE THE COMMITTEES ASKS.
SERIOUSLY WE HEARD YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR WHEN YOU SAID YOU WANT US
TO WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND GET THIS RIGHT I THINK
ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED
WITH A BIG BILL UNDERSTANDS I
HOW MUCH WORK IS INVOLVED IN IN
GETTING ALL THESE PEOPLE ON
BOARD AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS
WHILE STILL MAINTAINING THE
INTEGRITY THE BILL WHICH
ULTIMATELY IS ABOUT ADDRESSING
OUR- CRISIS WITH THE REST WASTE
MANAGEMENT. AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE HEARING FROM YOUR CITIES
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE JUST BEING
BURIED BY THE SHIFT. IN THE
WASTE MANAGEMENT CHALLENGE THAT
WE FACE. AND SO I YOU KNOW I
WILL SAY WE DO KNOW THERE ARE
STILL SOME GROUPS THAT ARE
OPPOSITION THIS BILL MANY OF
THEM HAVE A LITTLE HE POPPED UP
IN OPPOSITION IN THE FINALWEEK
BEFORE PASSAGE SOME OF THEM ARE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT. DID NOT
EVEN EXIST. A COUPLE MONTHS AGO.
I AND I GOT TO SAY THAT YOU
KNOW. WE WORKED REALLY HARD I'M
THEY'RE JUST SOME GROUPS OUT
THERE YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
SOME I'M SURE. I JUST DON'T
BELIEVE. AFTER ALL THE WORK
WE'VE DONE THAT THEY'RE JUST
SOME GROUPS OUT THERE THAT ARE
JUST NOT INTERESTED IN THE END
OF THE DAY. IN GETTING THE GAS
OR GETTING A NEUTRAL AND IT
SHORT OF GETTING THE BILL I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE WOULD
LOVE TO. SOME OF IT WILL MAKE A
STUDY BILL GREAT BUT WE REALLY
HAVE A CRISIS ON OUR HANDS HERE
WE WANT ADDRESS WE WANT TO
STRIKE WHILE THE IRON IS HOT.
AND WITHOUT MEMBERS ASK YOUR
RIVAL. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAY I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF REPUBLIC
SERVICES. LET ME OPEN BY
STATING THAT CHANGES
DISCONCERTING IT IS
DISCONCERTING TO ALL HUMANS AND
TO ALL BUSINESSES. BUT I'M
REMINDED OF AB NINE THIRTY NINE
THAT IMPLEMENTED OR CREATED THE
REQUIREMENT TO DIVERT 50% OF
OUR SOLID WASTE BY TWENTY
TWENTY. RESIDENTS CITIES AND
SOLID WASTE COMPANIES LIKE
REPUBLIC SERVICES PLAYED THEIR
PART OF MUCH OF IT WAS
UNCERTAIN BUT THE JOURNEY OVER
THE PAST THIRTY YEARS. WHILE
NOT PERFECT HAS INDICATED THAT
THE CHANGES BROUGHT BY A. B.
NINE THIRTY NINE WERE A GOOD
START BUT WE'RE NOT FINISHED.
THE CHANGE PROPOSED BY SENATE
BILL FIFTY FOUR AND ITS
COMPANION TEN EIGHTY ALSO
CAUSES REPUBLIC SERVICES SOME
LEVEL OF CONSTERNATION. BUT THE
ALTERNATIVE OF NO BILL TO
REPUBLIC IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION HAS
STATED THAT WE HAVE NO SKIN IN
THE GAME AS SOLID WASTE
OPERATORS AND I WOULD SIMPLY
POINT TO THE THIRTY YEARS OF
HISTORY THAT SHOWS THAT
RESIDENTS. BUSINESSES. SOLID
WASTE OPERATORS AND THEIR
CITIES HAVE ALL PITCHED IN. IN
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT ALL
PLAYERS FROM MANUFACTURERS
CONSUMERS IN THE SOLID WASTE
OPERATORS AND CITIES ALL HAVE
SKIN IN THE GAME. WE ARE ALSO
HEARTENED BY THE COMMITMENT
MADE BY SENATOR ALAN AND BY THE
OTHER CO AUTHORS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH A INFRASTRUCTURE
FEE BILL AND TO HAVE THAT BILL
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR. FOR
PURPOSES OF CONSIDERATION NEXT
YEAR. AND SO WE ARE ALL TAKING
A GOOD LEAP OF FAITH ONE THAT
WE THINK IS WARRANTED. GIVEN
THE WORK OF THIS AUTHOR AND
THIS STAFF. AND THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE'RE GONNA
GET THERE AND WE'RE GOING TO
SEE RESOLVE THIS PROBLEM AND SO
WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WE ARE RICHER AYE VOTE.
THANK TWO MINUTES EXACTLY
MANAGER MEMBERS AIR MARINO MAP
THE COMPANY GROW SOLICITATION
IN SUPPORT THIS MEASURE WE
REALLY WANT TO THANK CENTER
AROUND. AS A MEMBER GONZALEZ
AND SENATOR SKINNER STOP ALL
THE HARD WORK THEY'VE DONE I
CAN VOUCH FOR CENTER AROUND
WHEN HE DOES SAY THAT THERE WAS
A LOT OF WORK THAT WAS PUT IN.
BETWEEN THE FIRST TURN THIS
BILL AND WHERE WE ARE NOW
THEY'VE BEEN VERY MINDFUL ABOUT
THE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SPECIALLY TO FOOD. AND WE'RE
SATISFIED WITH OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL THAT
ADDRESS THAT GROCERY INDUSTRY
IS AS BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT OF
SUSTAINABILITY EFFORTS AND THIS
SENDS MESSAGES TO THE MARKET
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING
FOR. MORE RECYCLABLE SUPPLIES
MORE SUSTAINABLE SUPPLIES AND I
THINK THIS WILL HELP OUR
BUSINESSES ARE COMPANIES MOVING
FORWARD AND AGAIN APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE CENTER ALLEN
AND SIMILAR GONZALEZ AND- AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING A
TAPER ANY ANY FIXES THAT MAY BE
NECESSARY. BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
LIKE YOU SAID WE NEED TO STRIKE.
WHILE THE IRON IS HOT AND HAPPY
TO BE A PART OF THAT EFFORT.
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YOU
JUST LOSE NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT HIGH DENTAL
SLOPER FOR ABBOTT LABS IN
CALIFORNIA BEER BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTORS ASSOCIATION WOULD
LIKE TO THANK BOTH AUTHORS FOR
THEIR HARD WORK AND WE ARE
OFFICIALLY NEUTRAL THANK YOU.
WHAT ARE WE DONE IT WITHOUT A
ONE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. EMILY
RESTS WITH CALPERS AGAINST ON
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING JENNIFER
FEARING ON BEHALF OF SHANNON
STRONG SUPPORT. YOU SOMEONE
THAT IS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT. ERICA
MARTINEZ WITH EARTH JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT. QUOTABLES ON BEHALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT. A PERSONAL
CLOSE YOUR BEHALF THE STOP
WASTE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL NATIONAL
STARSHIP ACTION COUNCIL AND
THIS IS A SANTA MONICA LOS
ANGELES BEVERLY HILLS AND CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT. JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC
RC ON BEHALF OF THE STATE'S
THIRTY SEVEN RURAL COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS DIRT OFF HIM
HAPPILY CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. HI ERIC
POTASSIUM BEHALF RECOLOGY IN
SUPPORT. CARE MARTIN ST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. EXCUSE ME READ OUT US
ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES IN SUPPORT.
JONATHAN CLAN BATH THE CITY
EVEN SENATORS AND SUPPORT. THE
COP AS OF CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE IN SUPPORT. KILLER
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF SEVENTH
GENERATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HE NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS OF THE LA RIVER IN
SUPPORT. THE PREDATORS HIM TO
HAVE A C. R. IN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND
RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT. SUSAN
LITTLE ON BEHALF OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
STRONG SUPPORT. CARE TO SO ON
BEHALF OF HEAL THE BAY IN
SUPPORT. MELISSA ROMERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
SUPPORT. HELLO ON THE CITY'S
SOME HAVE A VIAL W. IN SUPPORT.
DOES HE BERNIE ON BEHALF OF
CALPERS STUDENTS IN SUPPORT.
WHEN CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA CREDIT
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. GEN
BABBITT ON ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEANS HIS LOBBYING COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. LOW INCOME
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. I
THOUGHT OF AND ON BEHALF OF US
SOON AND CALIFORNIA RELIEF AND
SUPPORT. ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
DAN JACOBSON TRANSPORT. JUST
LEARNED ON BEHALF THE COMPOST
COALITION AND WAS THE
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. GENESIS TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. SCOTT
SAILOR BEHALF OF THE DEFENDERS
WILDLIFE AND SUPPORT. DON
GILBERT FOR THE CONSUMER
HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATOR TAKEN
OUR AMENDMENTS AND WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE STAFF AND
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TO
NEUTRALITY. HAVE MORE SOME
WATSON ANHEUSER BUSCH NO
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL WITH THE
LATEST THAT OF A MOMENT THANK
YOU. ARE JUST FUND THIS WITH
THE CONSUMER TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE NOT NEUTRAL
THREE RECENT EVENTS THANK YOU
TO SENATOR AND HIS STUFF. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. OKAY ANYONE WISHING TO
VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THERE OF SOME WE'RE GONNA
GET YOU THAT. MY MICROBES HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE GLASS
PACKAGING INSTITUTE ON WERE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IT. REALLY
I THINK KATHY AND I SAW A LOT
OF THIS YESTERDAY SO I'M I'M
TRYING NOT TO REPEAT THINGS I
SAID YESTERDAY BUT- IN YOU KNOW
FOR MUCH OF THE YEAR THIS BILL
WAS. IN THE MEDIA AND
THROUGHOUT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BEEN FOCUSED ON PLASTIC
A PLASTIC POLLUTION PLATT IN A
REDUCTION OF PLASTIC WASTE ALL
VERY HONORABLE THINGS FROM THE
GLASS CONTAINERS. INDUSTRIES
PERSPECTIVE THERE'S TWELVE
FINDINGS IN THE BILL THERE'S
TWELVE FINDINGS IN BILL EIGHT
OF THE FINDINGS ARE AN
INDICTMENT ON PLASTIC. ALL
GOOD. THREE ONE FINING IN THERE
ABOUT PAPER CARDBOARD WASTE IN
THE BLOOD THE PAPER CARDBOARD
BOARD WASTE. THERE ARE ZERO
FINDINGS IN THE BILL DISCUSSING
THE PROBLEM OF GLASS GLASS
CONTAINERS GLASS WASTE THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO GLASS GARBAGE
PATCH IN THE PACIFIC OCEAN.
GLASSES MADE FROM NATURAL
MATERIALS IT'S MADE FROM IN A
SENSE MADE FROM SAND SO ACTION
LIMESTONE. AND RECYCLE GLASS SO
WERE WERE REALLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE WERE IN THE
BILL IT REALLY NEVER. WAS THAT
BIG OF A CONCERN WHEN THIS BILL
IS REALLY JUST ABOUT YOU KNOW
CREATING. A SCOPING PLAN AND
HAVING CARRY CYCLE LOOK AT THIS
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT THEN ON SEPTEMBER
SIX. BOTH BILLS ON. YOU KNOW
CREATED WHAT LEAD COUNSEL
READING RIGHT FROM THE DIGEST
CREATES A COP PROTECT
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATORY
SCHEME. IN CENTER THING THE
LEDGE COUNCIL CHOSE WORDS
SCHEME NOT A RATE FOR A PROGRAM
OF REGULATORY SCHEME. AND
THAT'S OUR THAT'S OUR ISSUE IS
THAT YOU KNOW THE GLASS
CONTAINER INDUSTRY DOES NOT
WANT TO BE PART OF A REGULATORY
SCHEME. FOR TO CREATE A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY CIRCULAR
PACKAGE FOR PACKAGE THAT'S
ALREADY A CIRCULAR PACKAGE GOT
GLASSES 1100% RECYCLABLE. THIS
HANDLE PROPERLY IT COULD. BE A
BOTTLE BECOME A BOTTLE ONE
BOTTLE CAN BE. NOW IN THE STATE.
pRECYCLED CONTENT IN THE IN
CLASS CONTAINERS MAIN
CALIFORNIA'S 35% RIGHT NOW
GLASS CONTAINERS MAY IN
CALIFORNIA MEETING A MINIMUM
RECYCLE I MEAN MEANING A
RECYCLED CONTENT STANDARD OF
FORTY THREE AND A HALF PERCENT.
THERE'S GLASS CONTAINERS MAY
ALL OVER THE WORLD ALL OF THE
COUNTRY AND IN A LOT OF THOSE
ARE COMING IN IT YOU KNOW FIFTY
OR 60% SO I HAVE YOU WRAP OF
YOUR COMMENTS AS YOU CAN I WILL
WILL SO WE PAY FEES ALREADY IN
THE BOTTLE BILL WE PAY FEES WE
PAY WE PAY FOR ALL THE THINGS
THAT THEY WANT TO WANT TO BE
COMPETITION THESE BILLS WE PAY
WE DO THIS ALREADY WE HAD WE
HAD SUPPORT A SECONDARY
PROCESSOR GIVES US MATERIAL. TO
TURN INTO A GLASS BOTTLE AGAIN
WE'RE DOING THE THINGS THAT
THESE BILLS WE WANT TO DO AND
WE REALLY JUST WANT TO BE OUT
OF IT WE DON'T WE DO NOT WANT
TO. GET SUB SUBJECT OURSELVES
TO A RATE TWENTY PROGRAM THAT'S
UNTESTED AND NOT UNKNOWN AND
PAYING REQUIRING US TO PAY FEES
THANK YOU FORTUNATELY THEY ARE
LABOR UNIONS AREN'T HERE THEY
WOULD OPPOSE BECAUSE ANY FEES
WE PAY INTO A PROGRAM. REALLY
COMES OUT OF THEIR HIDE YOU
KNOW THEY CAN'T NEGOTIATE THE.
ROCKER SEE WE'RE NOT PAYING
WAGES TO THEM. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER BY CHEN
MEMBERS KELLY ASTRON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL A NUMBER OF OTHER
REGIONAL WASTE ORGANIZATIONS.
IF WE HAD THIS HEARING WE COULD
NOT BE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL AND IT PAINS ME NO END
TO BE HERE ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE
BUT THE SEPTEMBER SIX
AMENDMENTS. LET US TO THIS
POINT HEARD OF SUPPORT
TESTIMONY FROM SEGMENTS OF THE
WASTE INDUSTRY A MOMENT AGO BUT
NOW YOU'RE HEARING THE REST.
AND I SAY A SLIGHT MAJORITY THE
WASTE INDUSTRY. WITH OPPOSITION
AND OUR CONCERN IS THE OPPOSITE
OF MR ROBESON'S WE DON'T WE'RE
NOT SURE WHEN THE BILL. TO THE
EXTENT THE BILL NOW CREATES A
PATHWAY AND ENHANCES. BILL THE-
AS THE VEHICLE BY WHICH
PRODUCERS CAN SATISFY THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE A
PROBLEM. LET ME BACK UP A
MINUTE I SPENT THE BETTER PART
OF LAST YEAR PROMOTING AS THE
SPONSOR. THROUGH MY CLIENTS SB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT RUBIO
I WAS DELIGHTED BUT SENATOR
ALLEN TOOK UP THE CAUSE OF
ADDRESSING NATIONAL SORT. THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IS IT IN
THE DRESSING THAT IT FAILS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT EPR PACKAGING
A. B. R. HAS NOT WORKED. IT HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF HARD TO HANDLE
MATERIALS IF THAT'S AS FAR AS
THE P. R. GOES WERE CONTENT
WITH THAT. BUT THE THREAT NOW
IS TO OVER A BILLION DOLLARS OF
EXISTING SOLD WASTE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. DEPENDING ON
HOW PARTICULAR PRODUCER CHOOSES
TO FULFILL ITS OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THE BILL. A GREAT AMOUNT
OF THAT MATERIAL COULD BE
DIVERTED FROM THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE NETWORK THAT
WE BUILT THE RELIES ON THIS
FEEDSTOCK FOR SUSTAINING ITS
OPERATIONS. I DARE SAY THAT A
LOT OF MY MEMBERS OF THE
ASSOCIATIONS ARE INDIVIDUAL
FAMILY OWNED BUSINESSES. HAVE
CONSTRUCTED MERSE PERSONALLY
GUARANTEED THE OBLIGATIONS HAVE
NO ASSURANCE THAT THEY'LL BE
OPERATING FOR THE THIRTY YEAR
TIME CYCLE YOU NEED TO PAY OFF
THAT. LOAN IF INDEED OF. THE P.
R. COMES IN AT ALL PACKAGING IS
NOW HAVE ANOTHER WAY BY
PRODUCERS. IF WE HAD MORE TIME
I COULD GO INTO MORE THIS. OKAY
WELL THAT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
ONE LIST OF THE CLIENTS THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER BUT THERE'S
STILL THREE REMAINING CENTER. I
WISH WE HAD MORE TIME AT WHICH
WAS IN SEPTEMBER SIX TO RESOLVE
THIS THE FIRST TIME. BUT THE
CRC SOUTHERN DISTRICT I CAN
TELL YOU REMAINS OPPOSED TO THE
BILL ALONG WITH THE OTHERS I
MENTIONED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING ADAM RIGHTLY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH TH
AUTHOR WE STILL OPPOSE THE
BILL. THE BIG GAP IN THE BILL
AS A LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
HOW TO PAY FOR THAT. WERE VERY
OPPOSED TO THE PENALTY OF
PERJURY FOR MISS REPORTING DATA
THANK YOU. NAME AN
ORGANIZATIONAL ONLY PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING A COOKING UNITS ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
STILL POSTING CAM. DON KHAKI ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO STILL POSTING.
JOHN YOU IT ON BEHALF OF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALL BE ON A WE HAVE THE
ALLMAN ALLIANCE THE CALIBER C.
DISSOCIATION CALIFORNIA GREEN
OF GRAIN AND FEED ASSOCIATION.
RIPPERS THANKS. MANY OF THE ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL OPPOSED.
DIRECTOR BEHALF THE PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION CENTER WE
APPRECIATE ALL YOU'RE TRYING TO
CONTINUE TO OUR WORK WITH YOU
THANK. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS POP OUR BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR RECYCLING IN
THE ENVIRONMENT IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANKS. GOOD
MORNING JOHN MOFFITT ON HAVE
WASTE MANAGEMENT THE ALLIANCE
OF AUTOMOBILE MANUFACTURERS IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING CATHY
LINE TO AMERICAN FOREST AND
PAPER ASSOCIATION AND WE WERE
NEUTRAL MOVED AND OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THANK. MORNING
MEMBERS JONATHAN CHOI WITH DARK
CONTAINER CORPORATION REMAIN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED BUT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE BILL
AUTHORS AND SPONSORS ON.
POTENTIAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING OF FUNDING FOR TWENTY
TWENTY WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THAT
COULD BE IN THE PIPELINE CENTER
IN LATER THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE BAKER WITH THEIR
AND READ THIS IS HISTORIC FOR
BEING A LITTLE BIT LATE I'M
HERE FOR THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM IN SUPPORT. YOUR
MEMBERS PAUL LET FELL DOWN WE
HAVE AS C. JOHNSON WE WERE
OPPOSE THE BILL ON TO THE
MEMBERS WERE ACTUALLY A NEUTRAL
NOW. THINK ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. CNN BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THIS LIMóN
THANK YOU I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR ANYTHING THIS
IS BEEN A CONVERSATION ALL YEAR
I JUST WONDERED IF YOU CAN
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS. I'M
PARTICULARLY I THINK THAT
RELATED TO WASTE MANAGEMENT AND
GLASS. WELL THANK YOU ANYWAY BY
THE WAY FOR FOLKS TO KNOW THE
NOTE THAT GOT PASSED TO HIM AND
WAS AT THE GOVERNOR REFUSE
RECYCLING COUNCIL JUST GONE ON
TO NEUTRAL. SO THE GLASS ISSUES
ARE. A CHALLENGE I THINK THAT
ON IN THE END OF THE DAY THE
GLASS HI IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST
MISTER OF HIS ABSOLUTE RIGHT
IT'S GOT A HIGH RECYCLING RATE
I IT'S A GOOD PRODUCT FROM ON
THE MACRO AFFRONT FROM A FROM
AN ENVIRONMENTAL PERSPECTIVE
AND THERE'S THERE WITH THE BIG
FOLKS INVOLVED WITH GLASS
WORKED WITH US THROUGH THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR THEY GOT
THAT WE CREATED A SYSTEM THEIR
THEIR BIG CONCERN WAS THAT THEY
WERE GONNA BE DOUBLE CHARGED
FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION. IN THE
C. R. V. PROGRAM AND WITHIN SB
FIFTY FOUR A. B. TEN EIGHTY AND
AS A RESULT WE STRUCK A DEAL
WITH THEM WHERE THEY WOULD
BASICALLY BE IN A FOR THOSE
FOLKS IN THE GLASS INDUSTRY WHO
WERE MEETING THEIR TARGETS
WOULD REMAIN IN SEE EVERY
PROGRAM AND THEN AT ALL THE WAY
UP UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
SO THEY WOULD BASICALLY BE
EXEMPTED FROM THIS PROGRAM
UNTIL THEN. AND THAT'S HOW WE
WERE ABLE TO GET THE BIG
PLAYERS IN CLASS LIKE THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
AND A LOT OF THE BEER FOLKS IN
IN OTHER BEVERAGE FOLKS TO MOVE
INTO A NEUTRAL POSITION THERE
IS THIS INSTITUTE THE MISTER
ROPES IN A REPRESENTS. THAT
CONTINUES TO HAVE CONCERNS I
CONTINUE TO BELIEVE IN AYE AYE
AYE AYE ENOUGH I'VE SPOKEN WITH
THEM WELL THAT ABOUT THIS STATE
THAT WE CAN WE CAN GET THOSE
ISSUES ADDRESSED BECAUSE IN THE
END OF THE DAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AN INDUSTRY HERE THAT
THERE REALLY DOES MEET THE
GOALS MUCH HI MUCH MORE THAN A
LOT OF THE OTHER FOLKS. WHO ARE
IN THE CONVERSATION I THERE'S
ALWAYS GIVE ME A CERTAIN DEGREE
OF NERVOUSNESS THERE WAS
NERVOUSNESS WHEN WE WERE HAVING
OUR NEGOTIATION WITH THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION
BUT I THINK WE MET THEIR. THEIR
CONCERNS BECAUSE THE END OF THE
DAY YOU KNOW. THEY THEY REALIZE
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE WE
WERE NOT UNFORTUNATELY BILL TO
GET EVERYBODY IN THE GLASS
COMMUNITY. ON BOARD. BUT YOU
KNOW. BUT MANY MANY PEOPLE IN
THE LAST COMMUNITY. HAVE
DROPPED THEIR OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE DOES HAPPEN TO BE THIS
ONCE A TWO DAY REMAINS
CONCERNED. ANDSO BUT I
CERTAINLY AM OBSOLETE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK. I WITH HIM
HE'S A FRIEND OF MINE AND I
THINK WE CAN I REALLY DO
BELIEVE WE CAN GET THERE I. YOU
KNOW IF WE HADN'T STRUCK A DEAL
WITH THE AB I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW THAT I WOULD BE QUITE
OPTIMISTIC BUT- I STILL THINK
WE CAN GET THERE WITH HIM. AND
WHEN YOU SAY WE CAN GET THERE
JUST BECAUSE OF THE TIME LINE
ARE YOU THINKING THAT I'M NOT
SAYING HE'S GOING TO. THAT NO
IN TERMS OF THE REGULATIONS AS
AS THE- INPUT AND THERE'S STILL
A REGULATIONS PROCESS RIGHT
THIS CREATES A STRUCTURED THIS
WILL BE REGULATIONS THERE WILL
BE PUBLIC INPUT IN THE
REGULATIONS. OR ISN'T THAT KIND
OF ACT THAT'S RIGHT ON A TIME
WHEN THERE'S AN INTENSE ROBUST
THE COLDER PROCESS BUILT INTO
THIS BILL. THAT WILL THAT WILL
INTIMATELY INVOLVED THE VERY
INDUSTRIES THAT WILL BE
INVOLVED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION REGULATIONS.
ASSOCIATE HERE AND SO THERE
WILL BE SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES.
TO ENSURE THAT THE FOLKS IN THE
GLASS INDUSTRY. THEIR CONCERNS
WILL BE ADDRESSED AS A SAY ON
THE NATURAL. THEY'RE ALREADY
PRETTY WELL PLACED. TO MEET THE
GOALS BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
RECYCLABILITY. ASSOCIATED WITH.
THEIR INDUSTRY. RIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS SOME. PARTY YEAH
THANK YOU. WELL FIRST OF ALL
CENTER AND I KNOW THAT CHANGES.
IS REALLY HARD. PUSHING THESE
ISSUES ANDTHAT'S WHAT WE SEE
HERE TODAY. NO THAT SAY THAT.
WITH THE THING ABOUT SOMETHING
SO BIG LIKE THIS WHEN WE'RE
PUSHING MAJOR CHANGE THAT HALF
THE PEOPLE ARE CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE OUTCOME
THE OTHER HALF 4100% CERTAIN
THE DOWNFALL OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO. ACHIEVE SO RIGHT SO
I GET THIS. YOU KNOW WE SEE THE
PLASTIC PROBLEM WITH OUR OWN
EYES THAT THE PUBLIC CERTAINLY
SEES THAT THEY'RE ASKING US TO
ENGAGE AND- I'M NOT CERTAIN THE
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO. CHANGE ON
THEIR OWN THEY HAVE A VESTED
INTERESTED. MAKE A LIVING MAKE
MONEY BY THEIR PRODUCTS. MAKE A
HANDSOME PROFIT AND- WAITING TO
SEE THAT OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
EVOLVE IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH SO
THAT'S WHY WE ARE WE ARE HERE
TODAY SO I SUPPORT THIS EFFORT
I DO HAVE SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES
MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE OPPOSITION. AND.
THEY KIND OF GO HAND IN HAND SO
ONE YOU TOUCHED ON THERE IS THE
COURSE THE INDUSTRY THAT MAKES
THE PRODUCTS WHICH THEY ARE
WHAT THEY ARE BUT THAT THE
PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE IN
LAYMAN'S TERMS THE HOLLERS AND
THE PEOPLE THAT SORT THE
MATERIALS I THINK THEY HAVE AN
INTERESTING PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN DAY TO DAY THE
BUSINESS OF DOING THAT SO IT'S
INTERESTING TO ME TO SEE ONE OF
THE MEMBERS. IN SUPPORT AND
YOUR IN YOUR STAR WITNESS AND
THE OTHER IN STRONG OPPOSITION
AND OF THE INDUSTRY AND ARE NOW
UNDERSTAND THE WHOLE
ASSOCIATION IS NEUTRAL BECAUSE
AS A NORTH SOUTH SOUTH SPLIT
AND BY RULES THAT IF THAT
HAPPENS THE WHOLE ASSOCIATION
IS IT IS NEUTRAL AND DOES NOT
OPPOSE THE BILL SO THANKS FOR
CLARIFYING THAT AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT THAT THEY BROUGHT
UP IS THAT THE UNCERTAINTY WITH
THIS IF YOU ARE PROCESS AND
HOW. THAT WOULD THROW A MONKEY
WRENCH IN THE ECONOMICS OF THIS
ALL WORK AND SO ON I KNOW YOU
PARTIALLY ADDRESS THAT IT MAY
BE REPUBLIC LARGER PERSPECTIVE
MAYBE A LARGER INTERNATIONAL
INTERNATIONAL IDENTITY MAYBE
THE SMALLER ONES ARE A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT SO BY WONDER IF
YOU COULD HELP. REASSURE HOW
THAT WOULD WORK AND IT GIVE I
GUESS TO MY SECOND QUESTION
MALES FROM OUT HERE RIGHT NOW
THAT'S ONE IS THAT YOU KNOW I
THE HOW YOU'RE LAYING THIS OUT
HERE IS IN YOUR EYES I WOULD
THINK IT'S BASED UPON
IMPLEMENTATION FROM CAL RECYCLE
AS FAR AS FLEXIBILITY THEM
UNDERSTANDING WAS
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE HI
MINTA PHASE AND LIKE WE DID
MAYBE IT'S ABOUT EXAMPLE LIKE
WE DID WITH THE GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT. GAVE A. R. P.
HOW WE THINK OF THEM TIME COME
UP WITH POLICIES REGULATIONS IT
WASN'T DONE OVERNIGHT AND BY
LARGE WE'VE ACHIEVED THE GOALS
OF THE TENT. TO GET AFTER BY
ADOPTING A MEASURE. SO THAT'LL
HELP. YES ON ON THE CHALLENGES
WITH IMPLEMENTATION YEAH AND
LET ME JUST SAY ON THE ISSUE
THE P. R. IT IS TOTALLY
PRIMITIVE NOBODY'S FORCED INTO
IT INCLUDING THE HOLLERS I AND
THE THING IS NO MATTER WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO STILL HAVE
PACKAGING PRODUCTS AND WE'RE
STILL GONNA HAVE TO MOVE THOSE
PACKAGING PRODUCTS AND GET
IMMERSED MICHAEL TO GET IT
TAKEN CARE OF SO NO MATTER WHAT
THERE WILL BE. HOLLERS AND
WASTE MANAGEMENT FOLKS
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS THIS DOESN'T CUT OUT
THE NEED FOR THAT INDUSTRY AT
ALL EFFECTIVE ANYTHING IT IT
JUST EMPHASIZES THE IMPORTANCE
OF THAT INDUSTRY HI I THINK
WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING YOU'RE
OBVIOUSLY RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THERE'S JUST NERVOUSNESS ARE
VIEWED THE VERY SPOKE TO BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE SPACE OVER
TIME I. HAVE GOTTEN USED TO THE
MODEL THAT WE HAVE. AND THEY
I'M- IN A EVERYBODY KNOWS THE
MODEL IS ACTUALLY FINALLY
BROKEN. BUT PEOPLE ARE NERVOUS
ABOUT ANY CHANGES MIGHT BE MADE
TO THE MODEL. AND WHERE THEY
FIT INTO THAT SPACE. AND I
THINK YOU'RE SEEING I THINK YOU
SEE I THINK YOU CORRECTLY POINT
OUT JUST DISPLAY IT BECAUSE IT
IS BASED ON THAT LEVEL OF
NERVOUSNESS. I WILL SAY THAT I
THINK THAT THE FOLKS WHO DO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. THE BILL
AND IT REALLY IS A SPLIT HERE.
ARE A WITHIN THE WASTE
MANAGEMENT BUSINESS
FUNDAMENTALLY RECOGNIZE THAT
DATE WILL BE. A CRITICAL PART
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION THIS
PROGRAM THEY'RE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE AND THEY WILL BE EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT AS A RESULT OF
WHAT WE DO. BECAUSE WE WILL
HAVE A MORE SOPHISTICATED
COLLECTION AND RECYCLING
SYSTEM. AS A RESULT
IMPLEMENTATIONS PROGRAM AND WE
HAVE BUILT THEM INTO EVERY
STAGE OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
PROCESS THE SCOPING PLAN. THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THEY WILL
BE A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION. SO I'M. YOU KNOW
IN THE END OF THE DAY THAT'S
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY I CAN
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION I HAVE A
SPECIFIC WITH THAT BUT TALK
MORE ABOUT. THE LONG TERM THAT
THIS THAT CAL RECYCLE
REGULATORY SCHEME I'M NOT SURE
HOW LEDGE COUNCIL. DESCRIBED AS
IS THAT HOW YOU WOULD JUST
RATHER THAN A REGIME I SUPPOSE
YEAH. BUT HOW WILL THAT WORK IN
PLAIN ENGLISH. YEAH WELL AS FAR
AS IS BILL BECOMES LAW. SO WHAT
HAPPENS IN THAT YOU'RE NOT
OVERNIGHT BECAUSE THIS HAPPENED
HOW IS THAT HOW DOES THIS PLAY
OUT SO YOU'RE ALL OF BORN IN
YOUR ON. YOUR ALLUSION TO THE
GLOBAL WARMING SOLUTION ACT IS
A GOOD ONE THOUGH I WOULD ONLY
SAY THAT WE HAVE ON. IT IN THE
SENSE THAT IT HAS CREATED A
CREATES STRONG GOALS. AND IT
SAYS FOLKS WE ALL GOT TO GET
TOGETHER AND MEET THESE GOALS
THESE GOALS ARE GOALS THAT ARE
SET BY THE LEGISLATURE WE WANT
YOU TO MEET THEM IF THEY'RE
IMPOSSIBLE TO. MEET THERE WILL
BE OFFENSE AND FLEXIBILITY BUT
WE NEED TO SEND A CLEAR MARKET
SIGNALS. TO AT TI INDUSTRY AND
THE ENTIRE MARKET THAT.
CALIFORNIA IS SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THIS WASTE
MANAGEMENT PROBLEM AND WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA. CHART A PATH
TO GET THERE. AND THEN BUT THE
BIG DIFFERENCE I SUPPOSE
BETWEEN. THE GLOBAL SOLUTIONS
MAN YOU KNOW GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT. IS THAT THERE'S
A MORE ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS BUILT IN WE HEARD
CONCERNS FROM FOLKS ABOUT. THE
EXTENT TO WHICH CAR WAS
PERCEIVED AS AND RESPONSIVE
AND- YOU KNOW DISENGAGED AND AN
IMPERIOUS AND WE'VE BUILT IN A
MUCH MORE ROBUST PROCESS FOR
EVERYBODY TO REALLY BE ENGAGED
IN. CREATING THE SCOPING PLAN.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD IS THE KIND
OF SUPPORT THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO BUILD BUT IN THE END OF THE
DAY. THE SAME. KIND OF MODEL IS
THERE WHICH IS THAT WE SET
STRONG GOALS WE CAN WIN POWER
OUR GOVERNMENT TO HELP US GET
TO THOSE GOALS. AND WE MAKE IT
WE DRAW A LINE IN THE SAND
ABOUT OUR SERIOUSNESS ABOUT
REACHING THOSE GOALS. BUT WE
BUILDING ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY TO.
I TO ALLOW US TO CHANGING
MANEUVER AND ADAPT TO THE
CHANGING TECHNOLOGY AS. WELL
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I DID NOT
WANT TO DO. A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY.
LAST TO THIS ABOUT HOW WE GET
THERE. WE ALL KNOW THEM WHO
WOULD HAVE IS THAT THE KIND OF
POWER WE'RE CARRYING A POP THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT DID THAT DIDN'T
EXIST YOU KNOW JUST A DECADE OR
TWO AGO. YOU KNOW THERE'S MORE
COMPUTING POWER IN THESE THINGS
AND THEN THE FIRST THE SPACE OF
THE TOOK COMMAND OF THE MAN IN
THE MOON. YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THERE CONTINUES TO BE
INNOVATIONS IN THIS WASTE
MANAGEMENT SPACE AMINU SORTING
MACHINES AND- AND NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOLLERS AND-
THAT WE DIDN'T ANTICIPATE A
BEFORE. AND THAT WILL ONLY
CONTINUE TO GROW I HOPE EVEN
FASTER NOW THAT WE WAY ONCE WE
PASS A BILL LIKE THIS WILL THAT
WILL SEND MARKET SIGNAL TO THE
ENTIRE WORLD. THAT THE WORLD'S
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IS
ACTUALLY TAKING THIS WASTE
REDUCTION GOAL SERIOUSLY AND
MARKET OUT OF RESPOND WITH NEW
SORTS OF TECHNOLOGIES AND
INNOVATIONS IN. AND WAYS OF
ADDRESSING AND SORTING AND- AND
ALL OF THOSE SORTS OF THINGS.
SO I. THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BIG
BIG PROBLEMS. IT ACTUALLY IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE CAN. I WHAT
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT YOUR
COMPARISON AB THIRTY TWO IS
THAT IN SOME RESPECTS. IT'S A
PROBLEM THAT WE KNOW WE CAN
HELP TO ADDRESS HERE. BUT THE
WE ACTUALLY. HAVE MORE
SOLUTIONS HERE THAN WE EVEN HAD
WITH A. B. THIRTY TWO THERE'S
MORE LOW HANGING FRUIT IN THIS
AREA WE KNOW THERE'S BETTER
PACKAGING OUT THERE. THE REASON
WHY SO MUCH INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
WILLING TO PLAY BALL WITH US IS
BECAUSE THE MORE MORE FORWARD
THINKING FOLKS IN INDUSTRY.
HAVE BEEN ACTUALLY DEVELOPING
THE PRODUCTS OVER THE YEARS TO
RESPOND TO MARKETS LIKE OURS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE SUSTAINABLE.
AND SO THEY KNOW THEY
COMMITTEES BECAUSE THEY KNOW WE
NEED TO MEET THESE GOALS WE
THEY KNOW WE NEED TO MOVE IS A
PLANET. TOWARD MEETING THE
KINDS OF GOALS. AND DONE AND
THE FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN FOOT
DRAGGING SOME OF YOU KNOW ABOUT
THEIR LIVES THEIR LITTLE IF
THEY'RE USUALLY FOLKS WHO HAVE
BEEN. BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL IN
TERMS OF DEVELOPMENT OF MORE
SUSTAINABLE PACKAGING. AND DONE
AND SOMETIMES YOU HAVE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THAT THAT
STRUGGLE WITH THIS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE SOME IN STATE FOLKS. THAT
HAVE BEEN REALLY GOOD IN THIS.
SPACE AND OTHERS THAT REALLY
DON'T WANT TO MAKE MOVES IN A
SPACE SO. BUT THIS IS
ULTIMATELY ABOUT SEND ABOUT
HELPING TO MOVE. THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM AND I MEAN GLOBAL.
TOWARD MORE SUSTAINABLE
PACKAGING. I BE IN BECAUSE IN
THE END OF THE DAY I SAID THIS
BEFORE TO THIS COMMITTEE. WE
WILL HAVE I WOULD DEEM THIS A
FAILURE. IF WE DON'T SEND THE
SORT OF MARKET SIGNALS GLOBALLY
JUST AS WE DID WITH SB THIRTY
TWO BUT I ACTUALLY WE CAN BE
MORE EFFECTIVE IN THIS SPACE. I
TOWARD MORE SUSTAINABLE
PACKAGING PRODUCTS. BECAUSE
EVERYBODY ALL OVER THE WORLD IS
DROWNING. IN THEIR POLLUTION
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW. HE FINISHED
RECORDING YOU FINISH MISS
GARCIA. AT THANK YOU AND SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK ON ON THIS BILL.
NHIáU SAID MISTER PRESS SAID
THAT THERE'S A COMPANION.
FINANCING INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
WORSE THAT AT CURRENTLY SO
WE'RE WE'RE INTRODUCING INTENT
LANGUAGE WE'RE AND WORD WHAT'S
NOT GOING TO PASS THIS YEAR ONE
IS THAT BEEN INTRODUCED I THINK
BE. AND SINCE WE DECIDED IS THE
LEAD AUTHOR AND IT I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY CAN CENTER SKINNER.
OKAY ART I THINK WE'LL PROBABLY
CENTER SKINNER SHE'S BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY IN OUR WORK AND
ALL THIS AND SO THE BUT WE WANT
TO SHOW PEOPLE WE RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT IN EVERY STRUCTURED
CHALLENGE HERE AND WE ARE
OBSOLETE. SERIOUS ABOUT
ADDRESSING. AND SO. IF THE IRON
IS HOT LIKE HE SAID WHY NOT DO
BOTH NOW AND WHY NOT THE LIVE.
SUPERMAJORITY LEFT THAT WE NEED
TO DO IT THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR YOUR BILL. IS COMING SOONER
OR LATER WHY NOT DO IT NOW AND
THE IRON IS HOT AND WILL FOCUS
ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK AS
YOU'VE SEEN. I WE TALKED ABOUT
THE NERVOUSNESS RIGHT WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING BIG WITH
SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO WE KNOW
WE NEED TO DO IT BUT THERE'S
ALWAYS. A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUSNESS. YOU KNOW YOU YOU
CAN APPRECIATE AS- A COLLEAGUE
I HOW CHALLENGING IT WOULD BE
TO. TO ADD ON THE ADDITIONAL
CHALLENGE OF MEETING A TWO
THIRDS HURDLE. I GIVE IN HOW
BIG A TASK WE HAVE WITH WITH
JUST WITH THIS BILL. BUT BUT I
WILL SAY THAT IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH INDUSTRY I THINK THERE ARE
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY
WILLING TO ACTUALLY. IT
ENTHUSIASTICALLY GAP BEHIND A
STANDALONE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING BILL I BECAUSE THEY
KNOW HOW NECESSARY IT WOULD BE
TOO. I TO REALLY EFFECTUATE A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS. BUT YOU KNOW
WE IN THE END OF THE DAY ON.
OUR WITHOUT PUTTING IN PLACE A
STRONG SET OF. OF GOALS THAT
ARE IN THIS BILL THERE'S JUST
NOT ENOUGH INCENTIVE FOR FOLKS
IN INDUSTRY TO REALLY GET
BEHIND IN THE WAY THAT WE WOULD
NEED IN ORDER TO REACH THAT TWO
THIRDS TRUSSELL. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT SINCE I FOR THE
FIRST BILL IN MARCH. LAST WEEK
THAT TIME TO TALK ABOUT IT YOU
STEP THAT DARREN A SIZE THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN A STRONG
SUPPORTER THIS IS SOMETHING HAS
COME UP IN THE OPPOSITION.
MULTIPLE TIMES FEE BILLS ARE
HARD A IN TWELVE YEARS OUTSIDE
THE BUDGET I'VE SEEN TWO OF
THEM IN A CARRIED BOTH OF THEM.
INSIDE CRISTINA HARD THE FIRE
BUT THEY'RE NOT IMPOSSIBLE BUT
I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THEY ARE.
I WORRY ABOUT WHEN IT'S TIME TO
START PAYING FOR THIS IN THE
SHORT TERM AND THE LONG TERM.
ARE WE EVER GOING TO HAVE THAT
WILL TO GET THAT FEE BILL DONE
ARE WE GONNA KEEP COMING BACK
AND SAYING HEY LET'S GET AYE
CAPTAIN TRADE. LET'S GET OUT OF
THE SPACE WHEN I FINISH REFER
ANSWER ME BECAUSE THAT'S EVEN
WHAT WE SEE IN WITH. OUR
COMPOSTING SITUATION RIGHT NOW
WE SET A GOAL AND HIGHWAY
HELPING FOLKS GET THEIR OR THE
MONIES ARE COMING FROM. ALONG
THE WAY AND SO YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN TOLD ALL OTHERS ARE GONNA
DO THIS NEXT YEAR THE YEAR
AFTER THE SEVEN YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN HERE I NEVER SEE THAT
FOLLOW UP. IF I MAY NOT DO I
BELIEVE THAT YOU HAVE A WILL.
YEAH I JUST HAVE CONCERNS YOU
KNOW ABOUT THAT FULL TIME PORT
AND I'VE BEEN BEHIND. ON BILLS
INCLUDING OR TALKING ABOUT. AB
THIRTY TWO SB THIRTY TWO ON HOW
I WAS MOVING AND SO FORTH.
ENTER I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THERE'S NOT A MERIT TO THAT
ARGUMENT THAT YOU'RE THAT
YOU'RE PUTTING OUT THERE I DOES
HAVE REAL CONCERNS ABOUT. ABOUT
THAT IN A I PERSONALLY THINK
THAT THE IRON IS HOT AND
EVERYTHING WE CUT OF THE
DENTIST THIS YEAR. WHAT A TIME.
THE DEADLINE FOR THAT WAS
YESTERDAY AS AN INTRODUCED. US
I KNOW THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET THAT DONE THIS YEAR'S I'M
NOT ASKING FOR THAT AT THIS
POINT BUT- I DO THINK THAT WE
COULD HAVE GOTTEN IT DONE IN
MUCH. WOULD HAVE BEEN A BIGGER
LEFT BUT I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT. THE AND I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE-
VOLUNTARY STURDIEST STORAGE A
PROGRAM OUT THERE. WE HAVE A
TRANSFER HOW DID THOSE BETTER
HERE WE HAVE ONE ON CARPET ONE
ON MATTRESSES A LOT OF TIMES
IT'S BEEN I LOOK THIS INCLUDING
IN MY OFFICE AND HOPEFULLY IN
THE NEAR FUTURE WE HAVE BETTER
MODEL SINCE THAT'S THE MODEL
THAT WE HAVEN'T FULLY GOTTEN
OUT THERE BUT A MODEL THAT WE
SHOULD EXPLORE. WHICH CREATES
UNSERVED POSSIBILITIES TRY TO
FIGURE OUT SOME OF THESE
FINANCING ISSUES AS WELL FROM I
WOULD DO ONE OF KNOWLEDGE THAT
YOU'VE- DONE SOMETHING IN THAT
SPACE I DON'T WANT TO. YOU KNOW
BE ALL OVER THE PLACE BUT- CAN
YOU EXPLAIN TO ME THE DECISION
TO BE MATERIAL NEUTRAL AND
BRING IN THE GLASS FOLKS INTO
SITUATION IF THEY ARE KIND OF
WHAT WE NORMALLY TRYING TO AS
THEY'RE DOING THEIR PART.
SETTING YOU KNOW WHAT WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT HOW LIKE THAT'S
THAT'S GOING TO CABLE WE ALSO
HAVE BEEN SPENDING. AT LEAST
THREE YEARS TALKING ABOUT
BOTTLE BILL ISSUES HERE I IN
THE COMMITTEE RIGHT AND POLISH
THAT WE HAVE THERE IN SO THE
CAN YOU THINK TO BE THAT THIS
ISN'T AS I WAS IN THE ROOM FOR.
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS AND I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA TELL ME WILL OF
THEIR READY DOING THIS ARE
GOING TO BE TAKEN CARE OF BUT
THERE'S THAT UNCOMFORTABLE
LESSONS OF I PUT THEM IN THAT
UNCOMFORTABLE NESS WHAT WHY WAS
THAT NEEDED. YEAH OKAY FIRST OF
ALL I'M TO BE YOU KNOW. THE
REAL FRANK WITH EVERYBODY GLASS
IS ALWAYS BEEN IN THE BILL FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING I YOU KNOW
IT'S TRUE THAT THE INTENT
LANGUAGES FOCUS ON PLASTIC AND
ANY OTHER DAY THIS PLASTIC AND
PLASTIC POLLUTION IS THE BIG
BIG BIG PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE. BUT
FROM A COLLECTION PERSPECTIVE
HAVING LASSEN IS VITAL I AND
EIGHT WE DID OFFER THIS PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT RELIEF TO GLASS IN
THE CONTEXT OF. OF C. R. V. AND
BASICALLY GIVING THEM THE
EXEMPTION BECAUSE OF THEIR
PARTISAN THAT THOUGH YOU THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE MEETING THEIR
RATES IN THE BOTTOM BILL.
THAT'S THAT'S A BIG BIG
EXEMPTION BUT IN THE END OF THE
DAY. IF YOU LOOK AT SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS ELSEWHERE IN THE WORLD
IT'S BEEN IT'S IMPORTANT TO.
INCLUDE EVERYBODY. I JUST CAN'T
HELP BUT FEEL AS THOUGH I AND I
UNDERSTAND I UNDERSTAND BUT I
THINK THIS IS JUST NERVOUSNESS.
ABOUT A BILL AS BIG AS THIS
FROM SOME FOLKS IN INDUSTRY.
BUT THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN IN THE
BILL IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
SYSTEM TO BE COMPREHENSIVE. OUT
WE MADE OF A MAJOR CONCESSION
TO GLASS WITH REGARDS TO OUR R.
C. R. V. AMENDMENT. AND YOU
KNOW THEY ARE JUST IN IN IN
SUCH A BETTER PLACE TO MEET THE
CORE GOALS OF THIS BILL. AND
THAT'S WHY I CONTINUE TO
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW
THROUGH THE COURSE OF AS THE AS
YET DIRECTOR PEACE COMES ONLINE
AND- WE START THE SCOPING
PROCESS I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN GET. MR OF SENATE
HIS CLIENT TO A PLACE WHERE
WAIT WHERE THEY'LL FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE WE'RE GOING. SO.
NOT UP YOUR TIME WITH A GLASS
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AND SO UP UNTIL
RECENTLY MOST OF US HAVE BEEN
CONFUSED THEN AND IT WASN'T
JUST ABOUT PLASTICS GLASS IS
ALWAYS BEEN AND THE BILL WAS
ALWAYS ABOUT WASTE. REDUCTION
THAT WAS. YOU'RE IN IN THE
LANGUAGE THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT THE PSYCHOLOGICAL FOCUS
HAS BEEN ON PLASTICS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO MAKE
THE MOST PROGRESS. I THINK YOU
NEED TO BE HONEST WITH YOU I
IT'S. I EVEN SAID THIS WHEN I
YOU KNOW WINS BUT THE GLASS
FOLKS CAME IN AND BEFORE WE-
CRAFTED IN IN IN. MAY THIS
AMENDMENT WORK ON THE C. R. V.
I TOLD THEM I AYE IF YOU WERE
THE LAST PEOPLE YOU'D EXPECT TO
BE HAVING LIKE A- WEEK BEFORE
FILE INTO SESSION CONVERSATION
WITH BECAUSE- YOU GUYS. YOU
KNOW ARE ARE ARE ARE SO GOOD IN
THIS SPACE IN IN IN GENERAL.
AND THEY SAY WELL WE UNDERSTAND
THAT AND THEY WERE WORRIED
ABOUT DOUBLE CHARGING THAT WAS
THEIR CORE CONCERNED THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO BE CHARGED FOR
BOTH THE BOTTLE BILL CRV. AND
FOR SB FIFTY FOUR SO THAT'S
WHAT WE CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA
OKAY LET'S KEEP YOU OUT. IN
TILL TWENTY TWENTY SIX OF THE
WERE YOU WERE YOU THERE'S NO
WAY THAT YOU WILL BE CHARGED.
FOR START UP COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH SB FIFTY FOUR TEN EIGHTY
TEN EIGHTY. AND THAT WAS ENOUGH.
BECAUSE I THINK THEY RECOGNIZE
WHAT WE WERE SAYING THAT IN THE
END OF THE DAY. THEY'RE THEY'RE
IN A STRONG PLACE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO TIE RECYCLABILITY GOALS.
ANY OFFICER OF SAN ANSWER YEAH
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY I I'M
I'M NOT DISPUTING ANY THAT IT
REALLY IS. WE DIDN'T FOCUS ON
IT BECAUSE IT WAS. EARLIER IN
THE YEAR IT WAS REALLY ABOUT
CARRY CYCLE SETTING UP A
PROCESS AND HAVING A SCOPING
PLAN IN DOING THIS AND THAT TO
GET TO A REGULATORY MECHANISM
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL SEPTEMBER
SIX WHEN IT BECAME APPARENT
YOU'RE GONNA RIP YOU'RE GONNA
REGISTER AND PAY RATE TORY
FEES. YOU KNOW IMMEDIATELY
THAT'S WHEN THAT'S WHEN WE GOT
A LITTLE MORE EXERCISED SO AND
THEN AND ALL THAT WORKS PLASTIC
CAME OUT OF THE BILL. SO. THE
PLOT PLASTIC NOT A LOT OF
PLACES THAT YOU'VE GOT A YOU
KNOW BECAME. IN AN ART THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT MY CLIENT
REALLY LOOKED AT IT AND SAID
WELL NOW IT'S NOT A PLASTIC.
I'M. I MEAN AT THE MISSILE AND
GAVE US A FOR ANSWER OF WHAT
WAS IN THERE AND WHAT MAYBE
LESS SPINE IN THE MEDIA OR WHEN
AND ARE PSYCHOLOGICAL IN OUR
HEADS SO AND I IN THE CITY
ANSWER. THIS CALL RECYCLE
HEREBY H. MR SCOTT SOME PLANTS
HERE. WHY DON'T YOU COME UP TO
THE TABLE AND- SEE IF. ANY OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
YOU. DID WERE YOU WERE YOU CAN
BE FRIENDS REAL SOON AND IF YOU
COULD EVER IMAGINE YOURSELF ON
THE MY. YEAH THIS IS THIS IS
THE START OF SOMETHING
BEAUTIFUL YET SIMILAR ERICA.
ALL RIGHT. MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SCOTT SMITH
LINE I'M THE DIRECTOR OF COVER
CYCLE. AT THANK YOU AND SO IN
THE BILL WE ARE GIVING CAL
RECYCLE REGULATORY FEE AT THE
ALREADY. A THIS BECAUSE I HAVE
A POSITION ON THE BILL. UP NOT
I'M NOT A POSITION TO STATE A
POSITION ON THE BILL OKAY I AM
HERE TO TELL YOU THAT AS
DRAFTED WE DO THINK. THE
DEPARTMENT CAN IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL. AND DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
OF HOW LARGE THE TASK WILL BE
OF IMPLEMENTING THE BILL ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT. FIVE EMPLOYEES A
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AT THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES DO YOU HAVE ANY CLUE
OF WHAT THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE
GOOD BUT IT'S A FAIR QUESTION
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION WITH ANY
SPECIFICITY BECAUSE- THE- THE
WAY THE BILL IS. CONSTRUCTED IS
THAT IT PROVIDES MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY TO THE PRODUCERS TO
DETERMINE HOW THEY COMPLY. AND
THEIR CHOICE OF COMPLIANCE WILL
IMPACT THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO OVERSEE THE PROGRAM. WITH
RESPECT TO THE FEE ITSELF I.
ANTICIPATE THIS WILL BE. OF OUR
SMALLER PROGRAMS BECAUSE THE
FEE IS STRICTLY FOR THE
REASONABLE REGULATORY COSTS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM
THERE'S NO WE'RE NOT GENERATING
REVENUE TO SUPPORT MARKETS FOR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IN THE
SPRING IN THIS. IN THIS BILL SO
THAT FEE WILL BE STRICTLY
LIMITED ON ON THAT BASIS. ON
THE TO THE EXTENT THAT.
COMPLIANCE IS DRIVEN THROUGH
ONE MECHANISM OVER ANOTHER. IT
WOULD IMPACT THE MAT RESOURCES
THAT WE NEED. TO BE DIRECT IN
RESPONSE THIS IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM AND IT WILL
REQUIRE. A SIGNIFICANT RESPONSE
FROM FROM THE MINISTRATION TO
IMPLEMENT. WITH WHAT'S ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF ANOTHER PROGRAM WITH
THIS TYPE OF DIVERSITY IN THE
FRONT END SINCE YOU'RE SAYING
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE FRONT
AND IF YOU BY DOING WHAT YOU'LL
HAVE TO DO. AND HOW HAS THAT
WORKED OUT. SO WE DON'T I CAN'T
THINK OF AN ANALOGOUS PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW MOST OF OUR STATUTES
THAT WE IMPLEMENT EVERY
SPECIFIC SO WE AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THE FOUR IF YOU ARE
PROGRAMS THEY'RE VERY SPECIFIC.
AND THAT WE IMPLEMENT THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM AGAIN IS VERY SPECIFIC
TO PRESCRIBE HOW HOW WE
IMPLEMENT THAT PROGRAM. SO WE
DON'T HAVE WELL THERE'S NOTHING
CONTEMPLATED IN HERE THAT IS A
COMPLIANCE MECHANISM THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING WERE UNFAMILIAR
WITH. WE DON'T HAVE AN
ANALOGOUS STATUTE THAT HAS THE
BROAD ARRAY OF COMPLIANCE
MECHANISMS AVAILABLE TO THE
PRODUCERS AND. THANK YOU THANK
YOU BYE YOUR FLORA. THANK YOU
CENTER SEE AGAIN I DO HAVE JUST
A COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS AND
WE'VE HEARD A LOT TODAY ABOUT
TRY TO REMOVE PRODUCT OUT OF
THE STREAM RIGHT MOVING WASTE
OUT OF THE SYSTEM. BUT I
CURIOUS IS WHERE WE SENDING
THAT MATERIAL. I WE HAVE IT WE
IT FEELS A LOT LIKE WE'RE GOING
TO REMOVE ALL THIS MATERIAL.
CHINA IS NOT TAKING ANY OF THIS
ANYMORE. WE'RE NOT DOING IT IN
STATE IN HER HARDLY. ANY OF IT
IN STATE. SO WHAT IS OUR
THOUGHT PROCESS IF WE'RE GOING
TO DO ALL THIS IF WE'RE GOING
TO MEET OUR GOALS. WE HAVE TO
HAVE A FACILITY IN A SYSTEM TO
HAVE TO PROCESS THAT WITHIN THE
STATE. SECURES YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT. YEAH OKAY SO FIRST OF ALL
THERE'S SOME REALLY GOOD
LANGUAGE IN HERE THAT WE HAD IT
IN ABOUT IN STATE JOBS
INCENTIVIZING POLICY TO
MAXIMIZE INCURRED IN STATE
MANUFACTURING USING RECYCLED
MATERIAL SO THAT WAS ADDED TO
SECTION FORTY TWO. ZERO FIFTY
ON ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
MENTIONED BY THE GENTLEMAN FROM
DART FOR EXAMPLE I HAS TO DO
WITH. AT SECONDARY MURPH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I MAY HAVE
THE OPTION TO GO VISIT A
SECONDARY MURPH. DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES THAT IS YOU KNOW DOING
A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
COLLECTING. TOOK INVOLVE THE
SET THAT GETS MISSED BY THAT
FIRST. BY THE BY THE PRIMARY
MARKS. ON ME THE DAY THIS IS
ABOUT REAL STRONG COLLECTION
AND THEN AND THEN CREATING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR UTILIZING
THAT MATERIAL. AND A LOT OF
IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING YOU DO
SEE A LOT OF IN STATE
MANUFACTURES AND SOME OUT OF
STATE THAT ARE DOING REALLY
GOOD WORK IN THIS SPACE ALREADY
AND I. YOU KNOW I OKAY BYE BYE
BUT THE NESTLE LAN NOT TOO
LONG AGO AND THEY ARE YOU HAVE
WON A PERCENT RECYCLED. YOU
KNOW PLASTIC BOTTLES THAT THEY
THEY STARTED MANUFACTURING AND
THEY'VE GOT OTHER ISSUES BUT
YOU KNOW THAT BUT THAT WAS A
REALLY IMPRESSIVE. TO SEE SAID
SAID THERE THERE IS
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT THERE IT
NEEDS TO GROW WE NEED TO BUILD
OUT AND WE DO WANT TO
INCENTIVIZE IT HAPPENING RIGHT
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF JOBS
OPPORTUNITIES AND- ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS RIGHT HERE AT HOME.
IN THERE AND THERE'S LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL THAT THAT SPEAKS TO
THAT. BUT THAT IS CERTAINLY ONE
OF THE THINGS. THAT WERE REALLY
HOPING TO KIND OF. PUSH UP
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION THIS BILL HI AT
THE END OF ANY COMMENTS MARK.
MADAM CHAIR THROUGH THE CHAIR
OF LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION GO AHEAD A AND THAT'S
THAT'S EXACTLY THE POINT. THAT
WE MADE IN OUR TESTIMONY
REGARDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FEE IN THE NEED TO GENERATE
REVENUE TO PROVIDE FOR THAT.
INFRASTRUCTURE UP. AND WITHOUT
THAT I THINK IT'S A IT'S A
CRITICAL COMPONENT THAT THE
THAT. UNDERMINES THE PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL AND SO. FORTH FOR
THOSE REASONS WERE VERY
ENCOURAGED THAT THESE AUTHORS
HAVE CHOSEN TO. COMMIT TO
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE FEE. FOR NEXT
YEAR. AND SO I HOPE THAT THAT
ADDRESSES YOUR QUESTION. BUT
THAT'S THAT'S INTENSE ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT. BUT A LOT OF WAYS I
FEEL LIKE WITHOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. WAS A WASTE OF
TIME. I MEAN WE'RE JUST GOT THE
CART BEFORE THE HORSE. BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT GONNA PROCESS HERE.
THEN WHAT ARE WE DOING. WE'RE
SHIPPING IT TO OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT ARE GOING TO BURN IT. AND
ALL THESE GREENHOUSE GASES ALL
THESE EMISSIONS THINGS WERE
TALKING. ABOUT GO TO OUT THE-
YOU KNOW JUST BY THE WAYSIDE.
AREN'T THEY THEY'RE ALMOST TWO
HORSES HELPING TO DRIVE THE CAR
RIGHT BECAUSE IN THE END OF THE
DAY. WITHOUT THESE KINDS OF
GOALS AND MANDATES. THERE'S NOT
GONNA BE ENOUGH INCENTIVE TO
BUILD OUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE WE
PART OF OR TRYING TO DO HERE.
IS SEND THE MARKET SIGNALS AND
THE REGULATORY SIGNALS. THAT
WILL HELP TO PUSH EVERYBODY TO
START TO TAKE THIS PROBLEMS
YEARS BECAUSE YOUR APPS YOU
RIGHT RIGHT NOW. ALL THIS STUFF
IS JUST GETTING IT'S A GAME A
TREE EYES. AND TALK AND SENT
OFF TO ASIA INCINERATED IT'S
GOING SENT TO OUR LANDFILLS.
IT'S GETTING IT'S ENDING UP IN
A RIVERS AND STREAMS. AND WORLD
DURING THE COST OF THAT RIGHT
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
SPENDING HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR JUST ON LITTER CLEAN UP
ALONE. THE RATES ARE ABOUT TO
GO OUT BECAUSE THE BOMBS
FALLING DOWN THE HALLWAYS
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. I AND SO
IT'S OUR TAXPAYERS IT. IN OUR
REPAIRS THAT ARE GONNA BE
BEARING THE BURDEN OF OUR
INACTION. AB SO THEY CAN I
DON'T CARRY CYCLE ONCE RESPOND
TO WHAT YOU MEANT. YOU TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IT BUT- RIGHT
NOW IN THE FEES. THERE IS NO
LIMIT TO WHAT THESE FEES CAN BE
CURRENTLY WITHIN THIS BILL
RIGHT. I KNOW WE HAVE NOT SAID
A- A FEE SCHEDULE WHAT WAS IT.
ABOUT TWENTY SIX IS THE LIMIT.
THERE ARE THERE THERE'S NOT A-
NUMERICAL LIMIT. BUT I DON'T
THINK IT'S ACCURATE SAY THERE'S
NO LIMIT BECAUSE- AGAIN. ONCE
THE BILL IS PASSED IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM RIGHT AND WHEN WE DO
THAT. THE BURDEN IS ON THE
DEPARTMENT. TO IMPLEMENT IN A
WAY THAT IS THE LEAST BIRDS
IMPOSSIBLE AND THAT INCLUDES
THE FEE STRUCTURE. SO WE ARE
GOVERNED BY THE RULES OF THE
OFFICE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW WE
PRODUCE REGULATIONS AND THAT
IS. PART AND PARCEL OF HOW. WE
HAVE TO DEVELOP THOSE RULES SO
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS THAT'S WHY AWAY ALL.
REVIEWS ARE RULES AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING IN THE LEAST
BURDENSOME. WAY POSSIBLE. SO
AGAIN AND ALSO TO JUST ADD THAT
THAT FEE. IS SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE COST OF. MANAGING THE
PROGRAM. SO I DON'T ANTICIPATE.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS THE DEPARTMENT WHETHER
IT'S- YOU KNOW THE WAY STE. THE
ENTIRE FEE THESE ARE ALL. VERY
HIGH TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT ONLY
MANAGING THE PROGRAM. BUT WE'RE
PROVIDING MARK INCENTIVES AND
PAYMENTS FOR THOSE FEES ARE
HIGHER. THIS FEE IS NOT GONNA.
AS DRAFTED DOES NOT INCLUDE
THOSE OTHER TYPES OF.
PROGRAMMATIC ACTIVITY. USUALLY
WHEN WE VOTE ON FEES LIKE THIS.
THERE'S A- A NUMBER THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT. THERE'S A THERE'S A
SET OF NUMBERS THAT WE CAN GO
BACK TO OUR CONSTITUENCIES AND
SAY HEY. FOR THIS PRICE WERE
DOING X. Y. AND Z. I DON'T SEE
THAT HERE. SO WE'RE GONNA JUST
MAKE A BLANKET VOTE. TO JUST
WILL ALLOW FEES TO BE INCREASE
AT CUT BY FRANKLY THE WILL OF
CAL RECYCLE. INTEL YOU GUYS GET
THE- THE MONEY YOU NEED TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM. I GUESS
THE CLOSEST ANALOGY WOULD BE.
IN ANY PR PROGRAM WHEN WE
IMPLEMENT ANY PR PROGRAM. WE
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO REQUIRED
THE STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION TO
COVER THE STATE'S COST OF
RUNNING. THAT PROGRAM THAT
WOULD INCLUDE. REVIEWING THEIR
PLAN RIGHT AND- ADDRESSING
ENFORCEMENT ETCETERA. SO I
GUESS WOULD BE ANALOGOUS TO
THAT SO WE WOULD DETERMINE WHAT
THE COSTS ARE JUST TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROGRAM. AND WE WOULD SAID.
I APPRECIATE THE CENTER TAKE
THE SONG BECAUSE THIS IS A HUGE
ISSUE BUT I MEAN AB THIRTY TWO
WAS MENTIONED A COUPLE TIMES
AND IT WAS HERE BEFORE I GOT
HERE. BUT BECAUSE OF THE SUCH A
BIG ISSUE IT WAS ALSO WE TOOK
TIME WE TOOK A COUPLE YEARS TO
DO IS A GOOD THING IN A BEING A
TO YOUR BILL. SO SOME OF THESE
ISSUES LIKE THIS I THERE'S
CLEARLY A LOT LEFT OUT HERE TO
BE DISCUSSED AND WORKED OUT.
YOU KNOW IT'S CERTAINLY MY
RECOMMENDATION WOULD TURN IT
INTO A TO YOUR BILL I KNOW
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT I CERTAINLY.
APPRECIATE THE TIME A CONCERN
FOR CENTER IN PROCEDURE YEAH. I
APPRECIATE THAT SOME MEMBER.
ONE THING I MENTIONED YOU KNOW
WE APPROVE. THAT THE SYSTEM
THEY SET UP WITH A PRICE THE
FEES THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND SO THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES
FOR US TO WIN THERE. AND THE
WHOLE THING IS TETHERED UNDER
PROPOSITION TWENTY SIX. THAT
REALLY DOES LIMIT THE. EXTENT
TO WHICH THEY CAN. ON YEAH.
THESE THESE SORTS OF FEES BUT-
THE OTHER THING I'LL SAY WITH
REGARDS TO THE DIFFERENCE IN
THIS IN A TWO THIRTY TWO. IS
THAT. MAYBE THIRTY TWO WAS
ADDRESSING A TRULY GLOBAL
PROBLEM. THIS IS A GLOBAL
PROBLEM AS WELL BUT IT'S ALSO
VERY MUCH A LOCAL PROBLEM. AND
IT'S HARD TO KIND OF PUT YOUR
FINGER ON DIRECT COSTS TO
CITIES AND TAXPAYERS AND
RATEPAYERS. WITH REGARDS TO
GLOBAL WARMING. I WHEN A. B.
THIRTY TWO WAS. WAS I WAS
PASSED. WE CAN. DROP A LIST OF.
HOW MUCH YOUR CONSTITUENTS
STAND TO LOSE. IF WE DON'T ACT
ON THIS PROBLEM RIGHT NOW TODAY
IN REAL DOLLARS. IT REAL
DOLLARS THAT IMPACTS CITY
BUDGETS REAL DOLLARS AN IMPACT.
YOU KNOW THE ENTIRE WASTE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM. I'M MISTER
MATHIS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THE AGAIN I MEAN THIS IS SIT
HERE AND I THINK BACK TO AB
THIRTY TWO I THINK BACK TO
THINGS WE'VE DONE WITH THE
WATER BOARD I THINK TWO THINGS
WE'VE DONE EVEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND WE
HEAR THE SAME ARGUMENTS.
MEMBERS EVERY YEAR THERE'S
ALWAYS THIS URGENCY OF WE HAVE
TO DO IT RIGHT NOW. AND WHEN
YOU REALLY DIG INTO THE
LANGUAGE OF THIS. WE'RE GIVING
THE AUTHORITY. TO CAL RECYCLE.
THAT'S THE AUTHORITY THAT WE
HAVE IS MEMBERS ME AND YOU
COULD SAY. YOU KNOW THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS SO YOU WANT. BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
WEIGH IN. AND THEY'RE GONNA
SIDE WITH CALORIE CYCLE OVER
US. THERE'S VETO POWER THERE'S
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS THAT
COME INTO PLAY. WE DEAL WITH
THIS EVERY SINGLE YEAR. AND. I
MEAN SENATOR YOU YOU CALL IT IN
POWER IN THEM BUT THE WHERE
WHERE I COME FROM WE CALL THAT
BIG GOVERNMENT AND GIVEN AWAY
POWER. YOU KNOW YOU YOU CALL IT
GOALS I CALL IT MANDATES. THE
THESE THINGS. NEED TO TAKE TIME
IT'S OUR JOB. AS LEGISLATURE'S
TO TAKE THAT TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE EASE ALL SIDES OF IT WE
HEARD IN THE TESTIMONY THERE
WAS PEOPLE THAT WERE IN FAVOR
GROUPS THAT WERE IN FAVOR
NEWMAN MITCH CAME NOW THEY'RE
NOT IN FAVOR. YOU GOT THIS BACK
AND FORTH. WITH THIS BILL. THAT
I THINK THE UNITING MISTER
FLOORS RIGHT I THINK WE TOOK
THIS IS THE TO YOUR PROCESS.
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
AND REALLY IRON IT OUT. WE CAN
MAKE THIS A LOT BETTER THAN IT
IS AND I KNOW THE ARGUMENT BACK
TO THAT IS GOING TO BE DON'T
LET THE PERFECT. GET IN THE WAY
OF THE GOOD. BUT THERE ARE SO
MANY THINGS AT STAKE HERE. THE
PROCESS THE MANUFACTURING HOW
ALL OF THESE THINGS GO TOGETHER
A LOT OF THIS CAME UP BECAUSE
THE TRADE WAR WITH CHINA WHICH
WERE NOW STARTING TO SEE AN END
TO. WE'RE STARTING TO SEE A LOT
OF THESE THINGS HAPPEN. AND I
MEAN. WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS THIS MOVES FORWARD
THERE'S ABILITIES TO REIN IT IN
THERE'S ABILITIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMPANIES ARE ABLE TO
ADAPT TO THIS THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE RIGHT THE TECHNOLOGY IS
HUGE BUT YOU CAN'T FORCE FED
IT. TO THEM. BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
SEEN. EVERYWHERE ELSE IS WHEN
CALIFORNIA FORCE VISIT TO
INDUSTRY INDUSTRY LEAFS EVERY
DAY OF THE WEEK. SO. I REALLY
THINK WE NEED TO DIAL IT BACK I
REALLY NEED TO THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS IN MEMBERS A I ASK
OF YOU WE'VE GOT TIME TO DO
THIS HOLD BACK LET'S TAKE. THE
EXTRA YEAR AND LET'S GET THIS
RIDE. BECAUSE IF WE KEEP ACTING
I MEAN THIS. I KNOW WE'RE IN
THE SOCIETY AND A NORMAL
MILLENNIAL AND IT'S LIKE HEY WE
WANT IT NOW. BUT LET'S GET IT
RIGHT. YOU ANYBODY ELSE. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND
MISTER ALLEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PLAY. BOTH MR MESSAGE THANK YOU.
NO I APPRECIATE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS IN ONLINE
I'M NORMALLY. ERR ON THE SIDE
OF A OF TAKEN TIME AND BEING
THOUGHTFUL BUT I'M SATISFIED
THAT CENTER ALLEN YOU SAID FORD
OF THE- A BOLD STEP ON A GLOBAL
CRISIS YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO
BRING IT BACK TO. WHAT MIND
PRIMARILY. CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
THE PLASTIC POLLUTION GLOBAL
CRISIS OF A WE SEE IN THE
UNITED NATIONS. I TO TAKE
ACTION ON WE SEEN THE EUROPEAN
UNION TAKING ACTION FOR AND
LIKE YOU SAID. WE AS THE
WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IS TRYING TO TAKE A BOLD STEP
SET THE STRONG GOALS. YOU KNOW
EMPOWER CALORIE CYCLE TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THAT THE THAT THE CLASS
FOLKS AND OTHERS THAT THAT HAVE
CONCERNS. BOTTOM LINE YEAH I
WILL JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN. AND
DRIVE THEIR KNOWLEDGE OF AB
THIRTY TWO YOU KNOW THIS IS.
JUST AS AB THIRTY TO ADDRESS
THE GLOBAL CRISIS OF. CLIMATE
CHANGE THIS IS ADDRESSING THE
GLOBAL CRISIS OF A PLASTIC
POLLUTION. AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE WHETHER YOU'RE
ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY OR
NOT. AND I BELIEVE THAT TO THE
RIGHT SAID HISTORY IS
SUPPORTING. THIS BILL. THANK
YOU Là MISTER ALLEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. MEMBERS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION HAN. YOU KNOW OUR
ANY ISSUE WAS RAISED ABOUT
TECHNOLOGY. AND ARE I SUPPOSE I
WAS JUST GONNA SAY TO FOLKS
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS THERE WE
ARE ALREADY HAVING INDUSTRY
STEP UP ALL OVER THE WORLD BUT
CERTAINLY TO ATTRACT CERTAIN
MARKETS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WITH THIS IS SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
SUSTAINABLE PACKAGING IT. THE
MARKET NEED TO LIVE OF
KNOWLEDGE TO PUSH US MORE IN
THAT DIRECTION HI THE VIRGIN
PLASTIC THAT HAS BEEN AT THE
HEART OF SO MUCH OF OUR
PACKAGING IS SO DAMAGING AND SO
COSTLY IN THE LONG TERM FOR ALL
OF US IN FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
AS RATE PAYERS AS TAXPAYERS AND
AS- HUMAN BEINGS. BUT THERE IS
TECHNOLOGY THERE IT'S RIGHT
THERE IT JUST NEEDS A LITTLE
BIT OF HELP THIS REMINDS ME OF
THE EXAMPLE OF LOS ANGELES IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN THE
AVERAGE KID WAS GOING UP WITH
HALF OF THE LUNG CAPACITY OF
KIDS GOING UP IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY BECAUSE HOW
TERRIBLE OUR SMOG WAS IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES. THERE WERE
SOME CARS ON THE MARKET THAT
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER
POLLUTING SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR THE SMOG
PROBLEM AND YET THEY WERE JUST
A LITTLE BIT MORE EXPENSIVE AND
THERE'S WASN'T ENOUGH INCENTIVE
TO GET THOSE OUT ON THE MARKET.
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
THE GOVERNMENT STEPPED UP AND
SAID LOOK YOU GOT TO DO BETTER
ON THE- STREET THEY KICKED AND
SCREAMED. THEY DIDN'T LIKE IT.
BUT THERE WERE INNOVATORS IN
THAT MARKET THEY'RE INNOVATORS
IN THAT INDUSTRY WHO STEPPED UP
GOT THOSE CARS ON THE ROAD. AND
NOW WE HAVE DOUBLE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE LIVING IN LA AND
BETTER QUALITY. EVEN THOUGH I'M
STILL DRIVING AROUND IN CARS.
HI AND SO IT THERE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE. IT EXISTS
TODAY. WE KNOW WE CAN SCALE
THIS. WE KNOW WE CAN DO THIS.
AND IF WE DON'T ACT. SOON WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
A CRISIS THAT IS DROWNING. OUR
CITIES. DROWNING OUR RIVERS AND
STREAMS. AND OUR CHILDREN AND
I. THINK THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE. FOR GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP. HI WE WORK REALLY
HARD TO GET TO A PLACE WHERE
ARE. WE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
BRING SO MANY DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER. TO
ADDRESS THIS GLOBAL CRISIS AND
BUT ALSO A LOCAL CRISIS THAT IS
IMPACTING EVERYONE OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TODAY. AND SO I
APPRECIATE THIS VERY THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION AND
I REALLY DO ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORD. THANK YOU WE NEED A
MOTION SOME OF SECOND. WELL DO.
MCCARTY AS OF THIS MOTION HAD
THIRTY CHOOSE THE SECOND WE
WERE ROLL CALL PLEASE. ITEM ONE
SB FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALLEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA
THOUGH FLORA NO CHILD. CHAU AYE
EGGMAN GARCIA. GARCIA NOT
VOTING LIMóN. LOW MOAN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA LINDA IS
NOT VOTING. DID YOU. READ
THROUGH GI STONE STONE AYE. SIX
TWO. EXCEPT TO THE BILL'S HOUSE.
THREE THEY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES READY
ABSENT MEMBERS. CAN YOU CALL
ROLE IN THE OTHER ON THE OTHER
ITEMS. ITEM TWO AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN CURRENT BEAU IS SEVEN TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT
MEMBERS GARCIA. MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING MURATSUCHI
WELL TO DO NOT VOTING. EIGHT
ZERO EIGHT ZERO THAT. THAT ITEM
PASSES THIS CONCLUDES OUR
MEETING THANK YOU. DOES NOT
ADVISE THE EGGMAN OKAY I'M
SORRY. WE'RE LEAVING THE ROLE
OPEN FOR FIVE MORE MINUTES FROM
HIS EGGMAN TAT ON THANK YOU